(bird chirps)
(bird crows)
- [Narrator] You know this
guy, William Shakespeare.
He's widely regarded
as the greatest writer
in the English language.
And here's Steve with
his Harris' hawk Margo.
Hi Steve.
What do they both have in common?
Let me explain.
So, what is falconry?
- Falconry is defined
as the art of using a
trained bird of prey flying at quarry.
Essentially it's catching your
dinner using a bird of prey.
- [Narrator] It's been
around for thousands of years
and it was so popular
back in the 16th century
that Shakespeare starting
using it in his literature.
He was such a prolific falconer
that everyone started using his phrases.
So much so, these
expressions are ingrained
in the English language today.
(triumphant trumpet music)
Like fed up.
- When Margo has been out
hunting, what happens is
she will eat until she
gets to a point where
literally she is fed up
to here, she is full.
She doesn't want to do
anything so she sits still,
looks miserable, and
therefore we say to people
like the kids, "Look at you
sitting there looking fed up."
(triumphant trumpet music)
(typewriter clicks)
All birds, for thousands
of years, have always worn
these two little jesses,
these leather straps,
attached to each leg,
and when we hold onto her
we put them under the thumb
and through the fingers.
Therefore we have restraint,
therefore we can hold him back
just like an errant husband.
All you've got to bear in mind is that
if something's been around for so long,
then it's bound to have an
impact on the vernacular.
(triumphant trumpet music)
(bird crows)
The falcon generally wears
a hood because they're very
highly strung, very
nervous, and the hood is a
calming down device.
What we do is when we put the hood on him,
we're actually fooling him
into thinking it's gone dark.
So you've tricked him, I
hoodwinked him, using a hood
to think it's nighttime so he relaxes.
(triumphant trumpet music)
As well as holding these
leather straps or jesses,
the leash fastens onto the glove and then
we wrap it around a finger,
it's like a belt and braces,
it's an extra precaution
in case we lose the bird.
(triumphant trumpet music)
(bird crows)
Haggard comes from an old
bird that has learned to hunt.
You trap her  once she's learned to hunt,
therefore she's a better hunter because
she's learned on her own,
which is where we get the word
an old hag from now.
How many people have used that every day
and don't realize it's
actually a falconry expression?
- [Narrator] So there we have it.
Thanks, Shakespeare.